okay this is kind of long but um you
wrote the forward
to maurice struan's a
cursed king series and consider yourself
a fan do you feel you drew any
inspiration
from robert of artois for the character
of gregor clegant
i'm sorry sorry the mountain that rides
i'm sorry i just did yeah no that's fine
the occurrence of king series was
certainly an influence on game of
thrones it's a it's
if you haven't read it it's a terrific
series of historical novels
uh written by a french writer named
maurice drawn
and it it's uh not fantasy it's strictly
historical it relates the uh you know
basically the fall of the capitian
dynasty
and uh the beginnings of the hundred
years war um
but it's got some stuff in it that's
almost fantasy like you know the
the curse of the templars and uh the
um the downfall of uh
of philip defer and all three of his
sons
and uh it's got poisonings and
impersonations and battles and
you know adulteress affairs and uh all
kinds of great stuff all straight from
history
um which is cool and part of uh
one of the secondary subplots does
revolve around
this this fight between two lords with
cousins actually
for this particular province and robert
artois is one of them and he is a big
blustering guy
i wouldn't say he was an influence on
the mountain at rides though uh
aside from being big um
as i recall his described was quite
large but
he's more like robert baratheon in in
some sense he's a big
blustering kind of hard drinking hard
living
sort of man the mountain is a kind of
quietly homosettle homicidal sociopath
um so they're very different
the birth of a dragon seems to be
connected to fire and death
does birthing a dragon require a human
sacrifice
[Laughter]
interesting notion i mean there are
clues
in the in the books uh so
you know i think i'm going to dodge that
one right now
this is sort of metaphysical is there
any connection between the lord of light
and the white walkers in terms of god
and the devil
no
[Laughter]
what would the signal and words of house
martin
be
[Laughter]
oh boy i i don't know i once designed a
shield
for myself when i was in the early ages
of uh
working on a series what the hell did i
put on it i think i put references to my
some of my previous books on it
um what would the words be
maybe deadline what deadline
[Laughter]
you